hi there if you look at this robot this
robot has learned to turn this valve by
itself now by itself isn't really
correct but it has learned it in a
semi-supervised duay with only 10 human
inputs along the entire learning
trajectory so only 10 times was there a
true reward for this reinforcement
learning procedure and the rest is
unsupervised discovery of this skill and
the paper were going to look at today
and the technique by which this was
achieved his dynamical distance learning
for semi-supervised and unsupervised
skill discovery by christian hart ich
einen shin yang yang thomas Hanoi WA and
Sergey Lavine so this is a technique for
reinforcement learning so they claimed
reinforcement learning requires manual
specification of a reward function to
learn a task right and they say while in
principle this reward function only
needs to specify the task goal in
practice reinforcement learning can be
very time-consuming or even infeasible
unless the reward function is shaped so
as to provide a smooth gradient towards
a successful outcome so what does this
mean let's look at it so if you want the
robot here to turn the valve to the
right right ideally you simply want to
say so the robot is here this is the
start state right ideal you just want to
say I want this right I want the fear
that the thing to turn to be at the
right so this is good all of this I
don't I don't want any of that right and
and and and the reinforcement learning I
mean this is enough this is reward
function right all of this is 0 and this
is 1 right this is a reward function and
in theory if you apply any sort of
reinforcement learning algorithm with
any sort of guarantee this should get
you there but of course we all know that
it's not that easy right there is
basically an exploration bottleneck
where
your robot has these three digits and
lots of joints to move around and the
the the probability that by itself it
discovered that it needs to do this here
and get this reward is very very slim so
what you want to do is in your reward
function that you're providing to the
robot you would want to say okay so this
here I see the the blue thing is a bit
more turn
so I'm maybe going to give this a 0.1
and then the here it's a bit more turn
so maybe this is 0.2 and this I really
like 0.3 here 0.6 maybe because it's
even more right and then one at the end
right so this is what they would call a
a smooth gradient in the reward function
where it's kind of the reward function
ramps up until the goal is reached but
oftentimes this isn't really possible
because if you already knew how exactly
to do the task which then you could you
can only shape the reward function truly
if you know how to perform the task in
the first hand and then why exactly do
you do reinforcement learning except for
as an academic exercise so the the issue
this paper has is is clear right what
they want to say is like let's let's
let's assume that your reward function
is actually pretty bad can we provide
artificially a way that this discovery
of these of these what they call of
these new skills is facilitated as if
the reward function had some sort of a
gradient so that's the the outset let's
actually go back to the to this for a
second and they have these mazes as as a
kind of a an example so if you look at
these mazes what we want to keep in mind
is let's actually draw this over here so
let's say you have one of these mazes
right and always there is a
there is a start state so you're here
and then there is a goal state right
let's say over here and the task is you
you can move up down left right and the
task is to reach the goal right but if
the reward function is simply that if
you reach the goal you get a reward of 1
and otherwise you get a reward of 0 then
all the agent can do is kind of explore
around right until it reaches the goal
now if you do random exploration like a
lot of a lot of reinforcement learning
algorithms for example Q learning or
policy gradient they'll have some sort
of a just over a random exploration
element where they if they don't if they
don't absent of what they of that when
they know what to do they just kind of
Google around like up up up right left
right left down right up that doesn't
work okay down down left down so they
it's sort of and then up again right and
then they just kind of wonk around
so this this method takes issue with
that and it says okay while the agent is
doing its thing trying to reach the goal
right what we can do is we can learn a
distance function between states now
we'll reduce the problem for now and
just say the task is always that the
goal state is reached in the shortest
amount of steps right so let's say the
the agent does something right it goes
here here here here and then here right
it that's that's one roll out of the
policy and then it crashed into a wall
okay that's bad so it gets a negative
reward right but in addition to that we
can we can learn so it has visited all
of these states here in between right
these are intermediate states this paper
wants us now to to learn a distance
function between the states so this
distance function let's call it D
it learns how far two states are away so
it'll you can you can tell it okay this
state here let's call that state a and
this state here state B how far are
those away now this is not super
well-defined yet but you want to say how
far are they away for this agent here so
the agent has maybe policy PI like
that's what it used to create this
trajectory under policy PI how far away
are states a and B and how far away is
simply going to be the amount of steps
that it takes the agent to go from A to
B so in this case that would be 2 right
so the D and you can do this between any
two states right this and this this and
this the right here here these all of
these states you can also start from
this state right let's do it another
different color and do every so DT the
this distance function D can actually
has a pretty tight reward signal like a
pretty wealth of information that it can
learn these things from write that so
the policy PI in this case can't learn
much because it just got a reward of 0
or something because it didn't reach the
goal but the distance function has very
very big reward or a big reward it has a
very dense reward signal where it can
learn distances between two states all
right now let's say we've explored a
bunch right a bunch we've had many
trajectories some here like two here and
then here
sometimes we even reach the goal right
so so sometimes we actually reach the
goal so we learn the D distances between
all of the the states now if we had a
perfect distance function let's assume
we have a perfect distance function our
task now becomes very very simple so
let's assume
that's so let's assume I'm here where
the green agent is and I have these I
can either go up or down and let's go
let's up let's say that's X and the down
is y all right
which one should I choose now without
even asking my policy per se what I can
do is I can ask hey distance function so
I can ask a distance function two
different things
so first let's do it like this distance
function what do you think of the
distance between X to the goal and what
do you think of the distance from Y to
the goal and the distance function if
it's learned correctly it will tell you
the distance of X to the goal is
whatever maybe you need eight steps the
distance of Y to the goal is ten steps
right so definitely you would go with X
right so if you had a good distance
function then you could solve the task
fairly fairly easily
now this by itself isn't super
interesting you will quickly notice that
if you are able to learn such a good
distance function especially with the
goal state here then you might as well
learn a good policy because that means
you've reached the goal a fair number of
times right so there the kind of
information theoretic signal of D versus
the signal on PI if you just want to
reach the same goal to me it seems the
same this this paper it tries to talk
this up I feel but to me if you are in
the situation where you have a fixed
goal and that's it then
this doesn't seem too interesting or too
beneficial with it compared to let's say
just learning a value function right
like you would do it in a three C or
something the difference between this
and the value function so if if if the
number of steps is actually your reward
so your negative reward you want to
reach the goal in the shortest amount
time then learning a value function is
the same the difference is for a value
function the value function simply takes
a state s right and the policy pipe
while the distance function takes a
state s and the goal state for the
policy PI the goal state for the value
function is implicit right so it
implicitly has the goal state because
you assume that the goal is always the
same with the distance function you can
technically change your goal and this is
where it becomes interesting so let's
say you've explored but you haven't
quite reached the goal yet right but we
said okay
most of these are algorithms they have
some sort of some notion of random of
random exploration right in order to to
reach the goal what if you went from
here to here and to here and to here and
you learn the distance is fairly well
for the trajectories that you can do but
you just haven't been able to go go any
further what you can say is you can go
to your replay buffer right your memory
of everything you've done and you can
ask which of these states has the
furthest distance from my starting state
and the answer will be okay this state
here as the furthest distance so now
what you can do is you can make this
your goal right you can just try to
reach that state right and once you
reach the state you can explore from
that state right because this is the
farthest away from your original
starting state that probably means that
you know if you that's kind of the
frontier of what you know so if you
explore from here you can go even
further notice because it is the
farthest that you know so it might turn
out that from here you can only go back
right so that's a possibility but
probably you could go even further right
so then you go further and you might
reach this state here right and again
you ask your
you replay before and tells you this
state here is the farthest so force he
take this as your new goal and now
you're just trying to reach that and
explore from here
this is extremely similar to an
algorithm like go explore that I already
made a video about where it remembers
what it did and then it it all will
always travel to the furthest states it
has seen so far and then from there try
to go further right so this this if you
can learn a good distance function here
that will help you in exploring the
space and eventually of course you think
you might actually reach this goal state
so you might go far enough into in this
maze you might explore it enough such
that you you stumble over the goal state
by itself all right so this is this is
sort of the goal this can be used in a
number of different ways now instead of
always going for the farthest what they
did in the robot is they just let the
algorithm explore right you explore
explore explore if this is like a state
tree and then at some point it asked the
human which one is closest to what you
want and then the human says this one
and then they say ah ok cool so this is
now the new goal right so we'll try to
reach this as much as possible and then
explore from here right so this in the
case of the robot the robot simply just
like does some things it explores in in
the unsupervised manner and then at some
point you ask the human which of these
things that the robot has done you like
the most and then that becomes the new
intermediate goal State and the
algorithm explores from there right so
that's the the main gist and how you can
use this now the entire learning thing
is actually pretty simple so what they
propose is simply to to learn the
distance function it be pretty pretty
formal here they say ok if you're two
states that were visited after one
another in
the episode then you can define the
distance function as the sum from I to J
if if the they were visited at time
steps I and J respectively this is a
discounted cost function across this but
ultimately they consider problems where
its shortest path problems so the cost
function simply becomes how many steps
does it take you to reach to reach the
goal so the cost function so this
becomes this this becomes the identity I
guess you can you can set it to 2 1 and
this you can also set to 1 so this
simply becomes J minus I how many steps
does it take you to reach the state in
time step J from the state you visited
in time step I and then they simply
train a poly neural network or I'm not
even sure if it's a neural network but
you train a bunch of a parameterised
function that learns to map the distance
between these states to how many steps
it took you from one to the other right
and you do this simply by having a by
regressing so mean squared regression
mean square is loss regression simple as
that and that's how you learn the
distance function and then you can use
the distance function in the ways we
discussed either to improve your
shortest path policy by giving it by
providing it so what you want to do is
you want to provide the distance
function as the negative reward right so
they say they they they provide the
distance function as a negative reward
for this or you can do this in an
unsupervised fashion where you always
propose the farthest away goes or you
can do this in the semi-supervised
fashion so they have a bunch of things
that they did here they have a bunch of
videos of things that they trained and
this is from the human
sorry from the semi-supervised where the
humans were simply selecting the hoppers
that went furthest to the right and you
can see over time this hops to the right
with very very sparse input only so this
is semi-supervised right and then it
goes to the right and it also has an
unsupervised video where you simply let
it perform and it um in unsupervised
fashion it tries to discover states that
are as far away as possible from its
initial States and you can see it
actually learns to move to the right and
to the left because these are these
reach states that are very far from its
original state right so that's it's
pretty cool that it turns out that the
the unsupervised method will discover
such states all right so what to make of
this this if you recognize this already
it's very plausible because I had seen
this some sort of this idea in many many
papers before so and they make some
connections in there related at work so
if you know for example Universal value
functions sorry universal value
estimation Universal value functions and
so on where basically it's also an
unsupervised way where you always just
each select two states you say this and
this agent now try try to go from here
to here right just try that and so it is
and then you'd select two new States
so you basically teach your agent to go
between two states that you choose at
random and it's supposed to in an
unsupervised fashion learn something
about the environment very similar to
what we have here right also a bunch of
other a bunch of other things like just
pure value functions are also pretty
similar
I think to this go explore there is a
big connection to go explore so this has
been around in one way or the other but
possibly not in this specific
formulation and what I think is cool
applied to this specific semi-supervised
task so if I had to formulate a
criticism to this method I would guess
that it probably doesn't work when let's
say the branching factor of the task is
super high you see here you can you can
only really turn the valve in one way or
another of course the digits and that
the joints are are they have they have
degrees of freedom but if you think if
the branching factor is super high right
so from from a given state here you can
go in many many many different ways and
then from each of those you can go in
many many different ways right then the
the notion of something being far away
right you go to this thing and you see
what's the furthest away all right is is
almost meaningless because you have so
much not explored right so if you have
if you are three steps deep here right
it will always tell you well this state
here is the farthest away but you
haven't explored these you know fifteen
directions here right so it might be
that you actually miss so that you you
go so here's the goal and here's the
start and you go a long way but you miss
this obvious shortcut here because you
always want to go along the longest path
around so it seems like there is there
are probably environments where this
works well right but there right but but
it appears that if if either the
branching factor is super high or if
there are maybe this this kind of loops
in the game loops between states
non-obvious combinatorial things it
might be somewhat even counterproductive
sometimes not not sure about that but it
seems to be very specific environments
where this would work alright so this
was my commentary I invite you to read
the paper check it out
and bye bye